hey andrew how's it going what's up man
my bestie keith actually is not
available right now but i was wondering
if you would be at all willing to come
with me on a food adventure so i'm just
like your backup um
we're doing pizza okay
sweet let's go
so where are we going we're on our way
right now to eat three different pizzas
at three drastically different price
points and we're gonna find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
what is the expensive one cost 135
135 is it made of gold why do you need
me to come with you because i need a
partner in crying and you are the best
friend today let me look up some dynamic
duo's and then we can decide which one
we are mickey mouse minnie mouse who's
who why can't we just be stephen and
andrew spaghetti and meatballs milk and
cookies i'll meet you inside butthead
mary kate and ashley olsen i think it's
pretty obvious what about three
musketeers
we're gonna serve for you today our
basic pizza it's our simple pie our
simple pies just tomato sauce parmesan
and a whole milk mozzarella as well as
our green stripe it's got basil pesto
mozzarella all natural chicken wild baby
arugula and roasted red bell peppers how
much is a simple pie at this location is
5.25 that's value right there or for
7.95 you can get as many toppings as you
like as much of them as you like pretty
great and here's the cool thing about it
just like any fine dining restaurant all
of our stuff's all natural so like how
many pies does this location make in a
day we've done over 1200 that's a lot of
pizza we're here the first pizza
restaurant not how i thought my day
would go but
all right there's pizza the side of your
head is five dollars can we cheers it's
really cool with the pizza
yeah like
yeah it's a great pizza this pizza's
called the simple pie it's very simple
and i think that's how you should do
things in life five dollars you're
getting the three things that make pizza
pizza you have good dough you have good
sauce you have good cheese this sauce is
delicious have you had this sauce yet
i've been eating the pizza all right
let's try the other pizza so we got the
most expensive pizza here and it's 7.95
cheers
this one is very good you demolish pizza
i know this is something that you're
gonna have to get used to i have no
self-control you are a pizza monster and
you
are a pizza plebian it's pretty good
next place that simple pie was great but
i would spend the extra three dollars to
get that pesto pizza i think i would
just get two simple pies instead pizza
[Music]
that's
fat
how it works i say that pizza
it's a fact i like pizza pizza facts
experts theorize that the price of pizza
in new york city will always equal the
price of a subway fare so if you have a
slice of pizza you can trade that for a
free ride oh i've had too much pizza
today we've only been to one place you
want a tootsie pop
[Music]
we're gonna make a brata pizza for you
today rata cheese is basically uh fresh
mozzarella preparation very soft rich
luxurious mozzarella cheese first we'll
stretch the dough and then we'll put a
little bit of olive oil on the crust
we'll top it with our passato which is
our tomato sauce and then layer the
squash blossoms over the top spread it
over the pizza it goes in the oven and
how do you know when it's finished one
of the true towels you turn it up on one
end and it'll stay like a board and then
it gets topped with the bread of cheese
a little bit of extra virgin olive oil
sea salt and black pepper it sounds
delicious what makes your pizza
different from other pizzas we focus a
lot on the crust the toppings are
important we put a lot of attention to
that but people don't know that that's
what makes the pizza so good they just
think it's the toppings but it's
actually the crust
[Music]
oh wow that is so good this pizza comes
in quarters i think that is awesome
these are all good slices cheers
cheers
that's a perfect pizza i'm calling it
right now we're not going to get a
better pizza than this
i just got into the crust the way that
really fresh popcorn tastes you got like
flavored air coming out of the crust how
are you not excited about this
do you get what i'm talking about you
know what's also interesting the pepper
yes i love putting black pepper on stuff
i put a disgusting amount on it my
girlfriend yells at me all the time you
have a girlfriend it feels like i'm
eating something that was prepared with
love
for me and you
and you and all of you guys out there
are you having a great time pizzeria
moza amazing 10 out of 10. stephen lim
pretty fun i feel like i'm starting to
get drunk off pizza where did you get
that pizza
pizza fact did you know that in 2001
pizza hut delivered a pizza to the
international space station can you
imagine eating pizza in space then i'd
be pissed off that they sent me pizza
hut pizza that's good what are you
talking about if you're sending it all
the way to space they could go ahead and
send you the best pizza from earth what
will it take for the next pizza to win
out
i don't know
i'm the chef to cuisine of spaghetti
beverly hills i will be making italian
white chocolate pizza that's in season
right now what's so special is the
truffle truffles are fungus and they
grow under the ground a pound of white
truffle would go as high as three
thousand dollars so a little piece like
this about 100 we will be stretching the
stove
to about nine inch diameter we'll put
mozzarella on top of the dough the dough
will go in the pizza oven for about five
minutes we use real wood fired oven this
will get somewhat uh smoky aroma once it
comes out we're going to shave a lot of
wood truffle that's it that's it three
ingredients as soon as you shave the
white truffle on it the aroma will just
explode it has its own distinct uh aroma
you can't find in anything else this is
135 from the menu actually a bargain
when we have a special ingredient like
this for us it's not about making money
it's more of us showcasing the
seasonality and sharing the beautiful
ingredients with the guests so we got
some white wine as suggested by the
chef
wow i already learned today that wine
goes delightfully with pizza are you
ready for this i don't know if i'm ready
a little apprehensive about eating a
pizza that might never be surpassed
again in my life the most expensive
pizza tip touch that's ever occurred
here we go
that's an indescribable taste you
already eat half the pizza yeah i like
pizza it is the best pizza i've ever had
in my entire life if i ordered this and
this dining room were full other diners
would be jealous the plate would come by
they'd all be turning their heads what's
that smell that smell is my dinner
it's a once in a lifetime experience
finally i've found a pizza that makes me
slow down and enjoy each bite we did it
we slowed andrew down i got us some
candy corn for dessert because we're
best friends now
which value was worth it the most the
five dollar pizza was amazing but it was
a little too formulaic i would go with
moza they've really honed and perfected
that craft spago was truly an out of
body experience but that wasn't a pizza
that was a truffle dish that happened to
come on a pizza i will also have to go
with pizzeria and mozart that viral
cheese was a game changer some of the
world's mysteries have been brought to
an end that's kind of sad it's like i
know that santa claus isn't real anymore
uh
[Music]
you want a piece of candy corn cleanse
your palate
do not ruin that pizza with candy corn
open up absolutely open up
just just give me one mouthful
[Music]